this is an average small town population
about 10,000 pleasant homes some
industry Main Street
one of the 10,000 and odd inhabitants is
an Weiland 14 years old and a student at
the local junior high and this is Roger
Cartwright he too is 14 years old and
goes to the same school and as attending
there are lots of things we could tell
you about an and Roger where they live
who their parents are what subjects they
like at school but one thing we don't
have to tell you it's plain as day Anand
Raju are healthy sturdy physically fit
nothing very remarkable about that for
most young people these days good health
is something to be almost taken for
granted well in have you ever stopped to
think why these young people like most
of us don't have to worry about their
health why is that so take this glass of
water for instance what does a glass of
water have to do with Anne's help it is
quite simple really when water falls
from the sky is rain it may be pure and
fit to drink but as it runs toward the
sea water may become polluted because
industrial wastes are discharged into it
and also because of the wastes coming
from terr cities when a drop of such
polluted water is observed under a
microscope it can be seen that the water
contains large concentrations of
microorganisms which can cause disease
like typhoid fever dysentery cholera for
example such microorganisms must be
removed before we can safely drink the
water in America even small communities
are assured of clean healthy drinking
water whether their water needs
purification or whether it is pure to
begin with and has not been contaminated
the Health Department keeps a close
watch over the supply to make sure that
only water that is safe to drink reaches
the people of the community and just
like water food too can carry dangerous
disease producing organisms
therefore to safeguard all members of
the community against the many diseases
which can be spread by unclean food your
local health department is concerned
with the purity of the many foods
consumed by the people each day rigorous
standards of cleanliness are established
for all places where food is processed
and handled everywhere the standards of
cleanliness are enforced by frequent
inspections to further safeguard the
health of a community proper disposal of
garbage is essential if garbage is not
properly disposed of disease organisms
from the exposed garbage may be spread
to food products in homes or restaurants
improper disposal of sewage may also
endanger the health of a community
rivers and streams may become polluted
swimming holes and beaches may be ruined
for recreation because sewage is
discharged into the waters of the
community such hazards must be
eliminated along with these
responsibilities the local health
department attempts and still other ways
to prevent or limit the spread of
communicable diseases scientists in the
Health Department help to identify
individual cases of the various
communicable diseases by making
laboratory tests at the request of local
physicians and whenever it is necessary
the local health department will supply
vaccines and other immunizing agents to
physicians and hospitals today most
physicians vaccinate infants and small
children against smallpox diphtheria
whooping cough tetanus and other common
diseases for which immunizing agents
have been developed and school nurses
who are usually public health nurses
working closely with a local health
department keep careful watch on the
health of students health education is
another important function of a local
health department pamphlets covering
many aspects of achieving and
maintaining good health for all age
groups are carefully planned
and widely distributed well all this and
much more is part of the picture of why
today we have good reasons to take good
health almost for granted Anand Roger
can live in their community without too
much danger from communicable diseases
thanks largely to the work done by the
local Department of Health but there are
other agencies the Red Cross for example
let's supplement the work of the
Community Health Department they are
voluntary health organizations supported
by contributions and frequently staffed
by volunteers and as a volunteer in her
local chapter of the Red Cross is
helping to prepare emergency kits for
use in a nearby disaster area one of the
many jobs the Red Cross undertakes to
supplement the work of existing health
agencies particularly in times of
emergency and then there are the many
other voluntary health agencies
concerned with the problems of specific
diseases some of these organizations are
concerned with research others with
rehabilitation and a tremendous burden
of caring for the victims of the
respective disease in many communities
there are visiting nurse services to
provide home nursing care for bedridden
patients the larger urban centres
frequently have a safety council to
guard against the many accident hazards
which occur on the roads in industry and
in the home and now together with Roger
we will come upon still another
safeguard which helps maintain the
health of a community yes the family
doctor nothing wrong with Roger as far
as he knows this is just a periodic
check up a routine examination to make
sure part of the job of a general
practitioner is to treat his patients
when they get sick but the community
health part of his job is to prevent
illness which is the chief purpose of
periodic checkups
by examining Roger carefully looking for
any telltale signs that might indicate
the possible onset of illness or some
condition that needs correcting the
doctor is helping to keep Roger well and
a community healthy
family doctors like this one and all the
other doctors the dentists the
specialists and the different branches
of Medicine the hospitals and clinics
the many laboratories that work with the
doctors all are part of the network of
people and organizations concerned with
the health of the community yes Roger
nan are pretty healthy young people
thanks in part to the work of the
community health services but these
services could not function so well
without the active cooperation of young
people and their parents of all the
other people who live in the community
in practically every community we have
important rules requiring us to observe
habits of cleanliness good personal
habits of cleanliness besides helping to
keep you healthy also reduce the chances
of your infecting others with disease
bearing organisms which you may be
carrying also everyone knows or should
know that bed is the best place for a
cold because what seems to be nothing
but a cold may be the beginning of
influenza or some other serious disease
if you don't stay in bed you in danger
not only your own health but also that
of the other people in the community
Roger and and understand the health
problems of their community they like
the rest of us must live by the rules of
healthful living for the sake of their
own good health and for the help of
their friends and neighbors
Community Health is responsibility
shared by all citizens young and old
alike how much do you know about the
health services in your community what
can you do to support or improve them
you